one of our big challenges was creating
the city of San fransokyo one of the
things about the storytelling of these
films is that as we embark on creating
the assets we're not always sure exactly
how they're gonna be used you heard
about the story development process and
it is constantly evolving sometime very
very late in the process so we were
lucky in that we had a fairly contained
setting for our film within the city but
we weren't sure where in the city so we
really embarked on a very ambitious
project to create the whole city so that
we could spend time pretty much anywhere
in the city and that would evolve as the
story came to be so San Francisco was
destroyed by an earthquake in 1906 and
they've been rebuilding that for a
hundred seven years but you're gonna do
it in one year that's that's right we
had to we had to be aggressive there's
no doubt about that one of the amazing
things that is possible at least in San
Francisco is you can go to the city
assessor's office and get data that
describes every lot every building and
you pay the whopping fee of $5 to obtain
that whole all that data so we use that
to recreate every lot in in town and
know what every building was that was on
each one of those Lots so if you go to a
certain corner on San fransokyo and
there's a five-story building in San
Francisco there will be a five-story
building in San fransokyo who's created
a detail on the map that it does down to
the number of bathrooms but we didn't
feel like we had to replicate that
exactly so we had our department create
very typical designs that would fit our
art direction style this mashup this is
one of the Sam you know pretty typical
San Francisco type apartment buildings
and then we analyzed these buildings and
said okay they're modular let's analyze
the modules let's get it rid of all the
repeats and then let's just build the
unique elements then we procedurally
created rule sets that would put this
building back together that's all well
and good but that doesn't help you very
much until you can use that and expand
on it and create variations on this
building so you can see here
is all the same modules put together in
different ways if that ever went a
little crazy then we would just
eliminate that as a possibility but this
gave us the ability to not hand create
every building that we needed and yet
have a tremendous number of amount of
variety which any real city does you're
describing kind of a technical and
analytical way to reproduce this
randomness how do you now interface with
the artists who will do the artistic
creation of what a building looks like
because there's architecture and design
and color and detail and how are you
describing to them this very statistical
and analytical approach well I mean I
think you heard about collaboration as
one of the the biggest things that is
important to our success there is no
doubt that our artistic teams our
technical teams are not separate teams
we are all unified in the creation of
these films and we have people that run
that entire spectrum from people who are
pretty much solely drawing to people
that in the middle who do both and then
people you know writing hardcore code so
it takes every one of those people to
create something like this so once we
have those buildings then we had to
populate them throughout the city and we
ended up creating I think 23 districts
that represent all of San Francisco and
as you can see there was over 80,000
buildings and all the attendant things
that are there in an actual city street
trees white poles there was traffic on
the streets there was crowds of
characters as you heard about earlier
and we really needed that vibrancy that
exists in in San Francisco or Tokyo